lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
pensar en la política monetaria la cual
es la política que puede usar el banco
central para afectar la economía hay que
hacer la diferencia de la política
fiscal recordemos que esta se encarga de
como el gobierno decide cobrar impuestos
o gastar de tal forma que resulta en
ajustes en la economía pero para
ayudarnos a pensar en la política
monetaria
usemos nuestro modelo de mercado de
dinero y como un pequeño repaso aquí en
el eje horizontal tenemos la cantidad de
dinero aquí tenemos determinado m1 el
cual es el efectivo el circulante y los
depósitos a la vista que son todas
aquellas cuentas de las cuales se puede
disponer efectivo y luego en el eje
vertical tenemos nuestra tasa de interés
nominal en este modelo suponemos que
tenemos una oferta monetaria
perfectamente inelástica que es esta
línea vertical y que no es exactamente
la manera en que funciona el mundo real
pero la usaremos así para el propósito
de este vídeo
y luego tenemos la demanda monetaria que
a una tasa de interés nominal alta el
costo de oportunidad de tener el dinero
en efectivo es muy alto así que la gente
no querrá quedarse con mucho dinero y
luego cuando las tasas de interés son
bajas el costo de oportunidad por tener
el dinero es muy bajo así que la gente
va a preferir tener más dinero en
efectivo por lo que la demanda monetaria
será más alta y en este punto en donde
se intersecta la oferta monetaria y la
demanda monetaria lo vimos anteriormente
es la tasa de interés nominal de
equilibrio pero debemos decir que este
es el mundo que estamos revisando y que
estamos en una brecha de producción
recesiva o brecha de producción negativa
y que tú eres el banco central de este
país que podrías hacer en general
podrías decir que sería bueno si las
tasas de interés nominal fueran más
bajas y así probablemente la gente
estaría dispuesta a pedir prestado más
habría más demanda de dinero y usarían
ese dinero para invertir o para consumir
más y podríamos acortar esa brecha
recesiva
pero como podrías bajar las tasas de
interés
bueno una manera sería incrementando la
oferta monetaria si pudiéramos mover
esta línea vertical a la derecha de
alguna manera pero cómo lo hacemos
hemos hablado algunas veces de que el
banco central
imprima dinero pero como logran en
realidad que ese dinero entre en
circulación como logran incrementar la
oferta monetaria bueno hay un par de
herramientas a su disposición una es la
idea de operaciones de mercado abierto
operaciones de mercado abierto y esta es
la herramienta más usada por el banco
central
digamos que este es un bono que
actualmente me pertenece y un bono es un
préstamo alguna entidad en este bono se
dice que se pagará con intereses en
algún momento en el futuro al poseedor
del bono y digamos que este es un bono
del gobierno lo que el banco central
probablemente hará y esta es la manera
en la que la mayoría de los bancos
centrales funciona será que dirá oye
quiere incrementar la oferta monetaria
entonces ellos dicen voy a ir al mercado
abierto a comprar un bono y
probablemente yo no sepa quién está
comprando este bono pero resulta que es
el banco central y así en lugar de
vendérselo a otra persona quien me daría
el efectivo que ya está en circulación
el banco central estaría introduciendo
un nuevo efectivo en circulación dinero
que acaban de imprimir y escribir
imprimir entre comillas porque no hay
mucho dinero físicamente o al menos no
tanto como antes
esto podría ser números digitales en
cuentas bancarias en ciertos lugares
pero esto funciona de la misma manera es
parte de la base monetaria y luego ya
hemos hablado de esto antes tenemos el
multiplicador monetario yo pondría esto
en un banco el banco prestaría una
porción de ese dinero con base en los
requisitos de reserva y luego quien sea
que lo obtuviera lo depositaría en un
banco y luego el banco prestaría una
cierta porción digamos que el banco
central me lo compra en mil pesos y
digamos que el requisito de reserva
actual es
al 12.5 por ciento bueno el efecto en la
oferta monetaria en este punto no será
simplemente mil pesos en lugar de eso
tenemos que mover mil pesos por el
multiplicador monetario y esto sería
igual a tenemos mil pesos ya que va a
ser igual el multiplicador monetario
bueno va a ser igual a 1 sobre 12.5 por
ciento es igual a 1 sobre 0.125 esto de
aquí es igual a 8 así que el
multiplicador aquí es 8 entonces el
efecto de comprar un bono de mil pesos
con nuevo dinero impreso por decirlo de
alguna manera efectivo impreso en
realidad sería aumentar la oferta
monetaria en ocho mil pesos un
incremento de ocho mil pesos en la
oferta monetaria obviamente un
oferta monetaria no es un gran problema
en una economía como la de los eeuu pero
imaginen que esto es mil millones de
pesos entonces esto sería ocho mil
millones de pesos y qué pasaría con esta
curva
esta curva se desplazaría a la derecha y
esta sería la oferta monetaria 2 y luego
este punto sería m2 y ahora cuál es
nuestra tasa de interés de equilibrio
bueno nuestra tasa de interés de
equilibrio nuestra tasa de interés
nominal se ha ido para abajo y esto es
el efecto que el banco central quería
ahora que las tasas de interés nominal
han disminuido la gente probablemente
pida prestado más para consumo para
inversión y se acorte la brecha de
producción negativa y también funciona a
la inversa imagina que en esta situación
que tenemos aquí estuviéramos en una
brecha de producción inflacionaria o una
brecha de producción positiva de alguna
manera la economía se está
sobrecalentando y el banco central
quiere enfriar las cosas lo que pueden
hacer es que podrían decir bueno si las
tasas de interés fueran un poco más
altas
eso podría ralentizar las cosas habría
menos consumo menos inversión y como
harían eso
bueno en lugar de hacer lo que hicieron
aquí donde compraron bonos para inyectar
efectivo podrían hacer lo opuesto
podrían tomar los bonos que tiene el
banco central y podrían venderlos y eso
sacaría dinero en efectivo del sistema
tomaría el efectivo del sistema tomaría
las reservas del sistema y produciría el
efecto contrario y movería la oferta
monetaria a la izquierda y tendrías el
efecto del incremento de tasas ahora
otra manera de mover la oferta monetaria
a la derecha oa la izquierda aumentando
la o disminuyendo la es cambiando el
requisito de reserva esto se hace con
menos frecuencia que las operaciones de
mercado abierto pero veremos que podría
tener el mismo efecto si el banco
central que puede determinar el
requisito de reserva quisiera cambiarlo
de 12.5 por ciento digamos que a 10%
entonces el multiplicador monetario el
multiplicador monetario hemos hecho las
operaciones en otros vídeos
iría de 1 sobre 12.5 por ciento iría de
8 a 1 sobre 10 por ciento a 10 entonces
las reservas existentes en lugar de
tener un multiplicador de 8 tendrán un
multiplicador de 10 y una vez más
tendrán el efecto de aumentar la oferta
monetaria ahora otra herramienta que
algunas veces se asocia con la política
monetaria es establecer una tasa de
descuento la ventana que ofrece una tasa
de descuento en los bancos centrales no
se usa tanto en situaciones para afectar
la política monetaria sino como un
mecanismo de seguridad en el sistema
financiero así que si un banco se está
quedando sin reservas y para mantener
sus compromisos con sus clientes puede
ir a la tasa de descuento del banco
central y pedir dinero directamente de
las reservas del banco central el banco
central establece una tasa de descuento
pero eso en realidad se vuelve operativo
durante emergencias cuando escuchas que
el banco central está estableciendo la
tasa en realidad están hablando de la
tasa objetivo de fondeo
y esta es la tasa a la cual los bancos
se prestan reservas entre ellos mismos y
los bancos están prestando entre sí a
tasas ligeramente diferentes pero lo que
la reserva federal el banco central hace
es establecer una tasa objetivo de
fondeo entonces lo que harán es apuntar
a una tasa objetivo de fondeo pero
generalmente usan operaciones de mercado
abierto para hacer realidad esta tasa
objetivo ahora lo último que quiero que
aprecien en esta discusión de política
monetaria es qué tan rápido pueden pasar
las cosas que el banco central hace para
aumentar o disminuir la oferta monetaria
para disminuir o aumentar las tasas de
interés nominal qué tan rápido pueden
ser sus efectos a menudo hay un retraso
aquí podría tomar un poco de tiempo para
que el banco central se dé cuenta y diga
oye parece que estamos en una situación
de inflación tal vez tengamos que
disminuir la oferta monetaria un poco
tal vez tengamos que sacar del sistema
un poco de las reservas o al revés si se
dan cuenta de que están en una recesión
generalmente hay un rezago una vez que
actúan y promulgan esta política
monetaria toma tiempo para que impacte
completamente en el sistema toma tiempo
para que las tasas de interés realmente
bajen e incluso una vez que las tasas de
interés han bajado podría tomar tiempo
para que la gente se dé cuenta de que
tal vez quiera pedir prestado y en que
usará ese dinero y para que todo esto
realmente impacte en la economía hasta
el próximo vídeo